I think most people
over complicated right if you're coming
to this you're coming to think media you
have something you're passionate about
it could have been a lifetime hobby I
mean it could be anything to be Star
Wars it could be whatever that is yeah
all in my model find your thing around
that make that your show for me that's
the daily financial news and then go
find four or five other amazing folks
who are willing to give you one hour a
week but don't want to have their own
channel but they like giving they like
discussing
it builds itself right you have to be
consistent I would tell if you're going
to start you can't do less than 100
videos right I think too many people
before judging it yeah before you're not
gonna find out your Rhythm your talk and
nobody watches the first hundred anyway
so it's like the first Pancake it
doesn't really look like anything yeah
right so just just just go for it two
things number one I've had too much
coffee today number two if you have not
seen our free master class yet you're
gonna love it if you're serious about
growing your YouTube channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class